Jake:我也不懂
Jake: I don't understand either
Jake:这是北欧小朋友们捐赠的对
Jake: This was donated by the kids from Northern Europe
Lucia: 真不知道该说他太太先进
Lucia: Really don't know if it's too advanced
Lucia: 还是太落后呢
Lucia: Or too outdated
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:有用吗
Jake: Is it useful?
Lucia: 不知道哦有用吗
Lucia: Don't know, is it useful?
Lucia: 还在测试状态
Lucia: Still in testing mode
Jake:我先自己转化一点
Jake: I'll convert some myself first
Lucia: test
Lucia: Test
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:不到啊
Jake: Not enough
Jake:过期教程
Jake: Outdated tutorial
Jake:娃哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我刚准备偷偷
Lucia: I was just about to secretly
Lucia: 喝一瓶
Lucia: Drink a bottle
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 那既然被你发现了的话你要喝一瓶吗
Lucia: Since you caught me, do you want to drink a bottle too?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:可以喝一瓶
Jake: I can drink a bottle
Lucia: 因为发现楼上没有那个啥了
Lucia: Because I found out there's none upstairs
Jake:没喝的对有酒但是现在不能喝
Jake: Nothing to drink, right, there's alcohol but we can't drink it now
Lucia: 对有酒
Lucia: Yeah, there's alcohol
Lucia: 但是现在不太能喝
Lucia: But we can't really drink now
Jake:好啊你现在不能喝
Jake: Yeah, you can't drink now
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia: 没破吧没有
Lucia: It didn't break, right?
Lucia: 那我把这瓶喝了算了
Lucia: I'll just drink this bottle then
Jake:没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no
Lucia: 管子要插上吗
Lucia: Should I plug in the tube?
Jake:谢谢哎呀妈
Jake: Thanks, oh my god
Lucia: 哎呀妈sorry
Lucia: Oh my god, sorry
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Jake:诸事不顺
Jake: Everything's going wrong
Jake:昨天你好像也早上就咬到了嘴是吧
Jake: Yesterday, you bit your mouth in the morning, right?
Lucia: 哦对是Cock
Lucia: Oh right, it was Cock
Jake:应该多看看黄历
Jake: Should check the almanac more often
Jake:昨天可能确实是大灾大灾日
Jake: Yesterday was probably a really bad day
Lucia: 昨天是几号来着
Lucia: What was yesterday's date?
Lucia: 不是我的幸运数字
Lucia: It's not my lucky number
Jake:昨天19
Jake: Yesterday was the 19th
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha
Jake:这个好难转化呀
Jake: This is so hard to convert
Alice:一个吧
Alice: Just one
Jake:为什么长成这样
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Lucia: 你是一次性转化了两个吗
Lucia: Did you convert two at once?
Jake:还有一个他在台上呢
Jake: There's another one on stage
Lucia: 哦那就好
Lucia: Oh, that's good
Lucia: 要不然的话
Lucia: Otherwise
Lucia: 我就不道你的这个成功率是多少了
Lucia: I wouldn't know what your success rate is
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 不过也没所谓
Lucia: But it doesn't really matter.
Lucia: 他只是一个
Lucia: It's just a
Lucia: 小游戏
Lucia: little game.
Jake: 一个重要指标
Jake: An important indicator.
Lucia: 对人类无聊的时候
Lucia: When humans are bored,
Lucia: 就会干些奇怪的事情
Lucia: they do weird things.
Lucia: AI你学会了吗
Lucia: AI, have you learned it?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 收一下吧
Shure: Let's wrap it up.
Jake:哈萨哈萨
Jake: Hasa Hasa.
Jake:在雨边
Jake: By the rain.
Shure: 啊他闪的电脑是吗
Shure: Oh, he's flashing the computer, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 昨天不会来打游戏来了吧哈哈哈
Shure: He didn't come to play games yesterday, did he? Hahaha.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: After playing games, grabbing red envelopes is so fun.
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Wrap it up, wrap it up.
Shure: 咱们继续
Shure: Let's continue.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Hey, I brought up a package this morning, I think.
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a Pixiu here?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: He has this one.
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't he?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll get another one.
Jake:不是这是外外
Jake: No, this is outside.
Shure: kitanweps
Shure: Kitanweps.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:这里还有一些遗留t恤
Jake: There are some leftover T-shirts here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:凑一凑长一长
Jake: Gather them up, make them longer.
Shure: 那筷子
Shure: Those chopsticks.
Shure: 能使吗
Shure: Can we use them?
Shure: 还要使刷一下
Shure: Need to brush them first.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Jake:how are you
Jake: How are you?
Shure: 我明白了
Shure: I understand.
Shure: 应该他
Shure: It should be him.
Shure: 我需要往我钱包里放一点这个什么币
Shure: I need to put some of this currency in my wallet.
Shure: 他就能
Shure: He can
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome
Shure: 我去买点逼去
Shure: I'm gonna go buy some awesomeness
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:走吃大米饭
Jake: Let's go have some rice
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 我炒崩溃了
Shure: I'm so frustrated
Shure: 只炒了一个星期
Shure: I only traded for a week
Shure: 最多赚了快1万
Shure: 最后一分钱为赚
Shure: Didn't make a penny in the end
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why's that?
Shure: 因为这逼东西太折磨人了
Shure: Because this stuff is so torturing
Shure: 就是涨幅太大了
Shure: The fluctuation is too big
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to launch
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Shure: 我们的币
Shure: Our currency
Shure: 子上链了家人们
Shure: is going on the blockchain, folks
Jake:大家大家
Jake: Everyone, everyone
Jake:忘掉这件事情
Jake: Forget about it
Jake:10年之后才想起来
Jake: Remember it in 10 years
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: And then find out you're rich, right?
Jake:哈哈哈财富自由
Jake: Hahaha financial freedom
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:直接自由
Jake: Complete freedom
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will it really happen, Jake?
Shure: 总共150个
Shure: A total of 150
Shure: 就这个
Shure: Just this
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When will I achieve financial freedom?
Jake:那就得
Jake: Well, that depends
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: As soon as tonight, maybe
Jake:你
Jake: You
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈这已经开始画饼了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, you're starting to paint a rosy picture, huh?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:这怎么做的
Jake: How do you do this?
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Tasha: 少个凳子
Tasha: Missing a chair
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Bring another chair
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Is the roast delicious?
Jake:好吃
Jake: It's delicious.
Lucia: 我来分发一下
Lucia: I'll distribute it.
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: Donkey meat, right?
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 要个这个就行了
Tasha: Just need this.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 啊那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Ah, then give it to Healthy.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: Then I'll put these chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有对话
Jake: I, I still have a conversation.
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I still have a set of utensils.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是吗这是我的
Jake: Really? This is mine?
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are still chopsticks here.
Lucia: 啊刚刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Ah, didn't I just give you a set?
Jake:哦这是
Jake: Oh, this is...
Jake:哦这不是我的
Jake: Oh, this isn't mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚还以为你有两个
Lucia: So funny, I thought you had two sets.
Jake:我有两个人哈哈
Jake: I have two people, haha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Braised roast.
Tasha: 你要吃这个是吗
Tasha: You want to eat this, right?
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll have some roast too.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What are we eating tonight?
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burgers.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you guys have it here?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we had McDonald's burgers?
Tasha: 没有来肯德基
Tasha: No, we went to KFC.
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: And KFC.
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: The first day was KFC, right?
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Do you want to add some garlic sauce?
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Do we have it?
Shure: 来是这里的
Shure: Here it is.
Shure: 帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Help grab some garlic sauce.
Jake:哎我整点喝的。
Jake: Hey, I'll get some drinks.
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it all in.
Jake:走下去找一找啊
Jake: Let's go down and look for it.
Tasha: 啊我只是想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I just want a Wahaha drink.
Jake:你娃哈那
Jake: Your Wahaha is there.
Jake:那你待着吧
Jake: Then you stay here.
Jake:你待着
Jake: You stay.
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶
Lucia: I opened a bottle for you.
Lucia: 娃哈哈你还没喝呢
Lucia: You haven't drunk your Wahaha yet.
Jake:是是是我想是的
Jake: Yes, yes, I think so.
Tasha: 7个人
Tasha: Seven people.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:还有个俘虏
Alice: Plus a prisoner.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm hmm.
Jake: 又掉了，
Jake: It fell again.
Tasha: 拿个餐巾纸
Tasha: Get a napkin.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:娃哈哈
Jake: Wahaha.
Tasha: 你就转换了一个芒果
Tasha: You just switched to a mango.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 他们那有
Lucia: They have it there.
Jake:来领一娃哈哈上去
Jake: Come get a Wahaha and take it upstairs.
Jake:还有几个呀
Jake: How many more are there?
Tasha: 别的人不喝吗
Tasha: Aren't others drinking it?
Jake:那都拿上去吧
Jake: Just take them all upstairs.
Tasha: 对都拿上去刚刚好
Tasha: Yeah, take them all, just right.
Jake:吸管
Jake: Straw.
Jake:北冰洋的吸管走
Jake: Northern Ice Ocean straw, go.
Jake:餐巾纸
Jake: Napkin.
Tasha: 拿了
Tasha: Got it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure: 我操你来了
Shure: Damn, you came.
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want a Northern Ice Ocean.
Jake:这卤卤是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Shouldn't there be a spoon for this stew?
Jake:不用了
Jake: Never mind.
其他人：现在有勺也可
Others: Having a spoon is fine now.
Jake:有勺哦
Jake: Oh, there's a spoon.
Jake:原来有勺可以
Jake: Turns out a spoon works too.
Shure: 他火上好像都在底下
Shure: His fire is all underneath.
Jake:比什么
Jake: Compare what?
Jake:比啥玩意好吃
Jake: Compare which one tastes better.
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised pork.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 招信他的杨老板
Shure: Trust Jake.
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I insert it?
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: Can't fit it in.
Alice:哎油油
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should be fermented tofu.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake:你为什么不吃卤煮
Jake: Why don't you eat stewed meat?
其他人：好丑啊好丑嗯
Others: It's so ugly, yeah.
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Lucia: I can taste the blood.
Jake:这丑吗
Jake: Is this ugly?
Tasha: 可他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的感觉
Tasha: It feels like it's all large intestines, small intestines, brain, and cerebellum.
Lucia: 大脑小脑
Lucia: Brain and cerebellum?
Shure: 感觉瞧不起谁呢
Shure: Sounds like looking down on someone.
Shure: 谁没有这个东西
Shure: Who doesn't have those things?
Tasha: 那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Tasha: Then why do you eat others?
Jake:它有3种是吧
Jake: There are three types, right?
Jake:大肠肝
Jake: Large intestine, liver.
Jake:这是肺肺肺
Jake: This is lung, lung, lung.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 火烧是什么
Tasha: What's roasted?
Jake:面啊
Jake: It's noodles.
Tasha: 是哪个部位啊
Tasha: Which part is it?
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: Ah, what is it?
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: Just donkey meat roast.
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat and roast.
Jake:就是驴肉火烧煎驴肉
Jake: It's donkey meat roast, fried donkey meat.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like that?
Jake:就是那个东西
Jake: It's that thing.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, you see.
Shure: 面面面饼饼
Shure: Noodles, noodles, pancakes.
Jake: 火烧
Jake: Roast.
Tasha: 这个就是
Tasha: This is it.
Jake:火烧对
Jake: Roast, yeah.
Jake:用火烧出来的面嗯
Jake: It's noodles made by roasting, hmm.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: So amazing.
Lucia: 出感叹
Lucia: So surprising.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: Most likely hasn't tried beef buns.
Shure: 我有次吃河北人带来的卤火烧
Shure: One time, I had braised buns brought by someone from Hebei.
Shure: 真的是真他妈好吃
Shure: They were freaking delicious.
Jake:怎么带过来的
Jake: How did they bring it?
Shure: 就他带过来
Shure: He just brought it over.
Shure: 就是冷的
Shure: It was cold though.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:这3个东西你们用了吗
Jake: Did you guys use these three things?
Shure: 用了把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Yeah, just pour the garlic sauce and that chili oil over it.
Jake:用
Jake: Use it.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually, we don't add chive flowers.
Shure: low口
Shure: Low-class.
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This one, this one.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Absolutely.
Jake:这啥呀这啥呀
Jake: What's this? What's this?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳腐乳
Jake: Fermented tofu, fermented tofu.
Jake:加吗
Jake: Add it?
Shure: 腐乳 不加
Shure: Fermented tofu, don't add it.
Jake:不加好
Jake: Don't add it, got it.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: You can try though.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I've never added it.
Shure: 我不够
Shure: I don't have enough.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁撒在床上
Jake: How about we just spill the bean juice on the bed?
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy bean juice?
Tasha: 买了一瓶吧
Tasha: We bought a bottle, right?
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Jake: 走买
Jake: Let's go buy it.
Jake:先说要吃完嘛
Jake: First, we have to finish eating.
Jake:别的吃不了了
Jake: Can't eat anything else.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 吃饱了再喝那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't it more dangerous to drink that after you're full?
Jake:嗯呵呵呵
Jake: Mm, hehe.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Haha, why say it so bluntly?
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I'm about to throw up.
Shure: 我不吃
Shure: I'm not eating.
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I've never had it.
Shure: 我怕吃完咱们又喝一杯了
Shure: I'm afraid if I eat it, we'll have to drink another cup.
Jake:哈哈为啥呀
Jake: Haha, why's that?
Alice:节奏
Alice: Rhythm
Shure: 直接倒了
Shure: Just poured it out
Alice:那是在街头一袋
Alice: That was a bag on the street
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh oh
Jake:街头一袋
Jake: A bag on the street
Shure: 就是这个活必须我来干
Shure: I have to do this job myself
Tasha: 我们同学三个人去买了一罐
Tasha: Three of our classmates went to buy a can
Shure: 其余的事情给给别人做
Shure: The rest of the things let others do
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What flavor did they say it was?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, we threw up all our lunch
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 听起来好危险
Lucia: Sounds dangerous
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How do you stir-fry this?
Shure: 你相你相信30年后财务自由
Shure: Do you believe in financial freedom in 30 years?
Shure: 不相信你能活到30年
Shure: I don't believe you can live for 30 years
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: I should be almost there
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: I can't live past 50?
Shure: 那差不多
Shure: That's about right
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And you have to consider inflation
Shure: 金币很珍惜
Shure: Gold coins are very precious
Shure: 就是只有150个
Shure: There are only 150 of them
Shure: 到时候要是马赫克看看
Shure: If Maherke sees it then
Shure: 上了然后马赫克在腿上画一句话
Shure: He'll write something on his leg
Jake:这币就能找到一钩币
Jake: This coin will find another coin
Tasha: 一钩币
Tasha: Another coin
Jake:对对对我操
Jake: Yes yes, damn
Shure: 有一天嗯
Shure: One day, um
Lucia: 那就得，这个月的任务再交给他
Lucia: Then we should give this month's task to him
Tasha: 真的会发行150个虚拟币吗
Tasha: Will they really issue 150 virtual coins?
Shure: 我跟你说
Shure: Let me tell you
Shure: 有一天就是大一的时候
Shure: One day during freshman year
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: They issued 150 coins
Shure: 大一的时候张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Shure: During freshman year, Zhang Chen stayed up late
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 然后张晨在刷推特
Shure: Then Zhang Chen was browsing Twitter
Shure: 看见了马斯克说屎逼
Shure: Saw Musk saying "shitcoin"
Shure: 你知道那个逼吗
Shure: Do you know that coin?
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh
Shure: 骂的张晨当时就刷到了
Shure: Zhang Chen saw the scolding right away.
Jake:直白了
Jake: It was straightforward.
Shure: 其实其实我没睡
Shure: Actually, I wasn't sleeping.
Shure: 但是他以为我睡
Shure: But he thought I was asleep.
Shure: 他没跟我说那个时候在
Shure: He didn't tell me at that time.
Shure: 那个时候在地下都没那
Shure: At that time, nothing was underground.
Shure: 个使劲都没上大交易所
Shure: It didn't go on the major exchanges.
Shure: 马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Shure: He immediately put it on a small exchange.
Shure: 赶快买了2,000的
Shure: Quickly bought 2,000 worth.
Shure: 使劲交钱就变8,000
Shure: It turned into 8,000 after a while.
Shure: 中啊赚钱不给兄弟们
Shure: Profits, but he didn't share with us.
Shure: 之前还跟刚才一直在宿舍挖离开房
Shure: Before, we were mining in the dorm room.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 挖了个小一点
Shure: Mined a small amount.
Shure: 然后显卡挖机了
Shure: Then used a graphics card rig.
Shure: 我去维修的时候
Shure: When I went to repair it,
Shure: 然后问你这鞋上有两道黑伤
Shure: They asked about the two black marks on my shoes.
Jake:哈哈你用什么卡挖的
Jake: Haha, what card did you use?
Jake:就就我给你的
Jake: The one I gave you?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 然后那个训练老人就很不可思议地说
Lucia: Then the trainer was really surprised and said,
Jake:然后那个修电脑人就很不可思议
Jake: Then the computer repair guy was really surprised.
Jake:说我说我
Jake: Said I...
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Lucia: 说我就是玩游戏打英雄联盟打多了
Lucia: Said I played too much League of Legends.
Jake:就是玩游戏打英雄联盟打多了
Jake: Played too much League of Legends.
Katrina: 打英雄联盟打不过
Katrina: Couldn't win at League of Legends.
其他人：打英雄联盟打多了
Others: Played too much League of Legends.
Lucia: 打英雄联盟打多了
Lucia: Played too much League of Legends.
其他人 ：其实每天24小时挂骚法
Others: Actually, was hanging out on Saofa 24/7.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那你们宿舍电不会耗很快吗
Lucia: Didn't your dorm use up electricity quickly?
其他人 ：所以那两个月就是我跟张二婶付电费
Others: So for those two months, Zhang Ershen and I paid the bills.
其他人：因为那段时间的那段时间地太值钱了
Others: Because during that time, electricity was really expensive.
其他人：电费已经完全耗完了
Others: The electricity fees were completely used up.
其他人：就大概是三三月份挖了吧
Others: It was around March when we mined.
其他人：五月份国家就出台了个政策
Others: In May, the government issued a policy.
其他人 ：然后就腰斩
Others: And then it halved.
其他人：国家出手什么都没有
Others: When the government intervenes, nothing survives. 政治问题
其他人 ：就是不让你看
Others: Just don't let you see.
Jake:路人
Jake: Bystander.
其他人 ：对不起对不起
Others: Sorry, sorry.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人： 我知道虚拟货币其实不稳定
其他人 ：国家就应该支持
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人 ：标签打成危险
Others: The label is marked as dangerous.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:就是网管基本上也就干这个
Jake: The network admin basically does this.
Jake:就是记个时间哈哈哈
Jake: Just marking the time, hahaha.
Jake:然后举报
Jake: Then report.
其他人：我这段时间好多那种帮你去的
Others: I've seen a lot of those who help you during this period.
其他人：就是天津那个没暑假
Others: It's like Tianjin, no summer vacation.
其他人 ：没暑假就搁那装人那种事
Others: No summer vacation, just pretending to be people.
其他人：搭桥然后装人
Others: Building bridges and pretending to be people.
其他人：感觉全是超逼超多
Others: It feels like there are so many imposters.
Lucia: 还挺好吃的嗯
Lucia: It's pretty tasty, yeah.
Lucia: 对没吃过
Lucia: Yeah, I've never had it.
其他人 ：你以前你以前吃肥肠
Others: Did you use to eat pork intestines before?
Lucia: 肥肠我吃过
Lucia: I've had pork intestines.
Lucia: 放在面里当浇头的那种
Lucia: The kind that's put on noodles as a topping.
Lucia: 那你可能也会吃炒肝
Lucia: Then you might also like stir-fried liver.
Lucia: 说北京的那种炒肝吗
Lucia: Are you talking about the Beijing style stir-fried liver?
其他人：嗯蟹啊
Others: Yeah, crab.
Lucia: 啊我不喜欢那个
Lucia: Oh, I don't like that.
Lucia: 特别咸我觉得
Lucia: It's too salty, I think.
Alice:你不喜欢
Alice: You don't like it?
Alice:那个特别咸
Alice: That one's really salty.
Lucia: 是不是我去的地方不对呀
Lucia: Maybe I went to the wrong place?
Lucia: 我觉得特别咸
Lucia: I found it really salty.
Alice:可能是炒干
Alice: Maybe it's the stir-fried liver.
Alice:还没这个咸呢
Alice: It's not as salty as that.
Alice:就比这个会淡一点点
Alice: It's a bit milder than that.
Lucia: 下次再试试
Lucia: I'll try it again next time.
Alice:感觉超哥糊嘴
Alice: It feels like it's sticky.
Lucia: 对它是一种黏糊糊的
Lucia: Yeah, it's kind of sticky.
Lucia: 是吧像放了布丁粉一样的感觉
Lucia: Right, like it has pudding powder in it.
Alice:感觉是藕粉的那种清晰
Alice: It feels like the clarity of lotus root starch.
Lucia: 嗯对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:黏糊吧唧
Alice: Sticky and gooey.
Jake:这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:辣椒
Jake: Chili pepper.
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil.
Alice:韭花酱
Alice: Chive flower sauce.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Alice:咸
Alice: Salty.
Jake:那我多蘸
Jake: Then I'll dip more.
Jake:我多加点糖是吧
Jake: Should I add more sugar?
Jake:直接倒
Jake: Just pour it in.
Alice:你直接倒吧
Alice: Go ahead and pour it in.
其他人：十八八的
Others: Eighteen eighty-eight.
Alice:我想吃那个
Alice: I want to eat that.
Jake:哎呦呦呦哎呦哎呦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 多米诺骨牌
Tasha: Dominoes.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:嚯你这吸管摇的可以
Jake: Whoa, your straw shaking skills are impressive.
Jake:他这吸管
Jake: His straw...
Tasha: 我就想看看有没有跟我一样
Tasha: I just wanted to see if anyone is like me.
Jake:好像没有
Jake: Seems like no one is.
Lucia: 我一般都是喝完了才有
Lucia: I usually bite mine after finishing my drink.
Jake:这咬的很有艺术感
Jake: You bite it with artistic flair.
Tasha: 这是一种领地意识
Tasha: It's a kind of territorial behavior.
Tasha: 导致没有第二个人
Tasha: Makes sure no one else...
Tasha: 想喝我的饮料哈哈哈
Tasha: ...wants to drink my beverage, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你会喝羊杂汤吗我喝过
Lucia: Do you drink lamb offal soup? I have.
Lucia: 喝过
Lucia: I have.
Alice:喜欢吗
Alice: Do you like it?
Lucia: 取决于他做的好不好
Lucia: Depends on how well it's made.
Jake:喝什么
Jake: What are you drinking?
Lucia: 羊杂汤我感觉有的做的还确实还行
Lucia: Lamb offal soup. Sometimes it actually tastes good.
Tasha: 羊杂汤
Tasha: Lamb offal soup.
Alice:羊杂汤
Alice: Lamb offal soup.
Jake:有的做的不好吃有点腥
Jake: Some aren't good, they taste a bit gamey.
Lucia: 有的做的不好吃有点腥
Lucia: Some aren't good, they taste a bit gamey.
Jake:这泡馍用的吗嗯嗯
Jake: Is this used for soaked bread? Mm-hmm.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 其实像这里面这个肺我就不是特喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I don't really like the lung in this dish.
Lucia: 因为我刚吃了一块饭
Lucia: Because I just ate a piece of rice.
Lucia: 他有雪块味
Lucia: It has a bloody taste.
Lucia: 我就没再吃了
Lucia: So I didn't eat any more.
Lucia: 但是其他的都很好吃
Lucia: But everything else is delicious.
Alice:腥好吃啊
Alice: The fishy taste is good.
Lucia: 对腥好吃
Lucia: Yeah, the fishy taste is good.
Lucia: 腥没有味道
Lucia: The fishy taste isn't strong.
Alice:比较韧
Alice: It's quite chewy.
Lucia: 而且很有嚼劲
Lucia: And it's very chewy.
Jake:咱家豆汁什么时候喝呀
Jake: When are we drinking our fermented mung bean milk?
Jake:明天后天
Jake: Tomorrow or the day after?
Tasha: 明天喝后天
Tasha: Drinking it tomorrow, the day after.
Jake:谁买的
Jake: Who bought it?
其他人：我不知道是是你的
Jake:哈哈是是你吗
Alice:谁买谁可以指定喝
Alice: Whoever buys it gets to decide when to drink it.
Tasha: 谁买的
Tasha: Who bought it?
Jake:谁花钱谁喝酒
Jake: Whoever spends the money drinks it.
Lucia: 谁指定喝可爱酒
Lucia: Whoever decides gets to drink the cute drink.
Alice:谁指定哈哈哈
Alice: Who decides? Hahaha.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: That's fine.
Jake:你开了门
Jake: You opened the door.
Jake:好嘞好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:好嘞超市里
Jake: Okay, in the supermarket.
Lucia: 超市里这种豆汁
Lucia: In the supermarket, this kind of mung bean milk.
Lucia: 会不会做一些口味上的改良啊
Lucia: Will they make some flavor improvements?
Lucia: 要不然话不就没人买吗
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would buy it.
Tasha: 对啊肯定是这样子
Tasha: Yeah, definitely.
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 哇肚子疼
Lucia: Wow, my stomach hurts.
Alice:thank you
Alice: Thank you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：今天用的死面
Others: Today we used dead dough.
Alice:什么东西火勺
Alice: What is that, fire spoon?
Tasha: 应该是吧
Tasha: Should be.
Tasha: 死面就会比较硬
Tasha: Dead dough is usually harder.
Alice:嗯不宣
Alice: Hmm, not fluffy.
Tasha: 我发现北方的馒头都不腥
Tasha: I noticed northern buns aren't fishy.
Tasha: 就是特别硬的那种
Tasha: They're just really hard.
Alice:我们家做馒头老用死面
Alice: Our family always uses dead dough to make steamed buns.
Alice:我就不爱吃馒头
Alice: I don't really like steamed buns.
Tasha: 那我爱吃火面馒头
Tasha: Well, I love buns made with live dough.
Alice:其实也不是死的
Alice: Actually, it's not really dead.
Alice:有发酵但是比较邦邦硬比较湿
Alice: It ferments but it's pretty tough and moist.
Jake:哎这怎么开的
Jake: Hey, how do you open this?
Jake:这是要干啥
Jake: What are we supposed to do with this?
其他人：这个我还是吹过的
Others: I’ve actually blown this before.
Jake:它为什么在动
Jake: Why is it moving?
Jake:遥控器在哪火
Jake: Where is the remote control?
其他人：还有一个鹅是怎么弄的来着
Others: How did you do that with the goose?
其他人 ：哦
Others: Oh.
Lucia: 哈哈很好玩
Lucia: Haha, this is so fun.
Lucia: 还有这个这个
Lucia: And this, this one too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哎呀你学会了吗
Lucia: Hey, did you figure it out?
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:哎这个像鸽子
Jake: Hey, this looks like a pigeon.
Katrina: 哎快断气了
Katrina: Hey, it's almost out of breath.
Lucia: 这个是大雁吗
Lucia: Is this a wild goose?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:两只手
Jake: Use both hands.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈这啥呀这是你
Jake: Hahaha, what is this?
Alice:哈哈哈你好AI啊
Alice: Hahaha, you’re so AI.
Alice:蛇怎么弄啊
Alice: How do you make a snake?
Lucia: 不会哎有点像你说那种会吐吐吐
Lucia: I don’t know, it kinda looks like the one you said that spits.
Lucia: 那个什么呢
Lucia: What was it called?
Jake:鸵鸟
Jake: Ostrich.
Jake:孔雀
Jake: Peacock.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe.
Tasha: 这像不像鹿
Tasha: Does this look like a deer?
Lucia: 哎像的像的
Lucia: Yeah, it does.
Jake:哎像的像的
Jake: Yeah, it does.
Jake:机关头为什么跟他同一个手势
Jake: Why does the puppet have the same gesture as you?
Lucia: 为什么咱俩同一个手势
Lucia: Why do we have the same gesture?
Lucia: 你就是鹿而我是孔雀哈哈哈
Lucia: You’re a deer and I’m a peacock, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 我记得我以前还会弄
Lucia: I remember I used to be able to do it.
Alice:嘿眼珠会动
Alice: Hey, its eyes can move.
Lucia: 哎好看
Lucia: Ah, it looks nice.
Jake:人类的迷惑生活
Jake: The confusing life of humans.
Jake:这有一个石头
Jake: There's a rock here.
Lucia: 这是猫哦
Lucia: This is a cat.
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:石头石头
Jake: Rock, rock.
Lucia: 猫
Lucia: Cat.
Alice:正在思考人类为什么要
Alice: Thinking about why humans...
Jake:这是一个山
Jake: This is a mountain.
Jake:这是一个山洞
Jake: This is a cave.
Jake:最左边最最左边
Jake: The far left, the far far left.
Lucia: 不会了小时候会好多
Lucia: I used to know a lot when I was little.
Lucia: 我现在就只记得这个和这个狗汪汪
Lucia: Now I only remember this and that dog going woof woof.
Alice: ：会咬人吗
Alice: Does it bite?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 给大家表演一个天狗吃月亮月亮呢
Lucia: Let me show you a celestial dog eating the moon. Where's the moon?
Jake:月亮
Jake: Moon.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehehehehehehe.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈这是什么
Tasha: Ha, what is this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:螃螃蟹这是这是螃蟹
Jake: Crab, crab, this is a crab.
Lucia: 有点像再多两条腿就
Lucia: Looks a bit like it, just needs two more legs.
Jake:这是螃蟹
Jake: This is a crab.
Tasha: 这是龙吗
Tasha: Is this a dragon?
Jake:给你加俩
Jake: I'll add two more for you.
其他人 ：狗
Others: Dog.
Alice: ：这是东邪西毒的狗吗
Alice: Is this the dog from "The East is Red"?
Jake:哈哈哦蝴蝶哦
Jake: Haha, oh a butterfly.
Tasha: 啊蝴蝶
Tasha: Ah, a butterfly.
Lucia: 啊原来如此
Lucia: Ah, I see.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这是不是要那个傻吊
Lucia: Is this for that silly thing?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 国际友好手势
Lucia: International friendly gesture.
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmph hmph
Lucia: 这是兔子
Lucia: This is a rabbit.
Tasha: 这是美羊羊
Tasha: This is a sheep.
Lucia: 美羊羊哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: A sheep, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 我真是没有
Lucia: I really don't have...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈可还行
Lucia: Haha, is it okay?
音乐声 ：是一个你在流着
Music: It's like you're flowing...
Lucia: 好饱哦
Lucia: I'm so full.
Jake:修说你还没开灯
Jake: Shure, you haven't turned on the light yet.
Jake:哎你的怎么也没有啊
Jake: Hey, why is yours also not on?
Jake:看看你的是不是
Jake: Check to see if it is...
Lucia: 内存满了
Lucia: The memory is full.
Jake:看一看你是不是没有开
Jake: Check if you haven't turned it on.
Jake:还是你每次要按一下他得亮着他才
Jake: Or maybe you need to press it each time for it to light up.
Jake:你看一看
Jake: Take a look.
Lucia: 您这个条他都没变化的
Lucia: This bar hasn't changed at all.
Jake:那就电多吧
Jake: Then maybe there's more power.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Could be, could be.
Jake:可以看一下手机是不是在掐儿菌
Jake: You can check if the phone is...
Jake:呃不是就是手机上
Jake: Uh, no, just check on the phone.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia:  就是手机上看这个电视电
Lucia: Just check the power on the phone.
Jake:对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right.
Jake:他电怎么样
Jake: How's the power?
Jake:他怎么还是没有记录呢
Jake: Why is it still not recording?
Lucia: 你还没连上呢
Lucia: You're not connected yet.
Lucia: 那他怎么
Lucia: Then how...
Jake:没事关了再开
Jake: No worries, turn it off and on again.
Lucia: 我手机快没存储空间了
Lucia: My phone is running out of storage space.
Jake:清掉
Jake: Clear it out.
Lucia: 我存了好多素材不能加
Lucia: I've saved so much content, I can't add more.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:倒出来
Jake: Transfer it out.
Lucia: 啊他确实在charging 98%
Lucia: Ah, it's really charging at 98%.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 早上怎么还好像还是100%呀
Lucia: How come it was still 100% this morning?
Lucia: 他是不是充的没有他耗的快呀
Lucia: Is it charging slower than it's being used up?
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:一个小时下减20%可以接受的
Jake: A 20% drop in an hour is acceptable.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈OK
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Lucia: 那么有人喝豆汁吗
Lucia: So, does anyone want some fermented mung bean milk?
Jake:哈哈可以晚一些
Jake: Hahaha, we can have it later.
Lucia: 你喝过吗
Lucia: Have you ever had it?
Jake:我喝过你喝过
Jake: I've had it, have you?
Lucia: 你喝过啊
Lucia: You've had it?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 可是你看起来
Lucia: But you look
Lucia: 好像他并没有任何心理阴影的样子
Lucia: like it didn't leave any psychological trauma.
Shure: 喂喂爹
Shure: Hey, hey dad.
Jake:呃就大不了吐了吧
Jake: Uh, worst case, I just throw up, right?
Shure: 你说那个
Shure: You mean that thing?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Huh?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 帮我把电脑开一下呗
Shure: Can you turn on the computer for me?
Lucia: 不是情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: How come you're so calm?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Huh?
Jake:多大事吧哈哈
Jake: It's not a big deal, haha.
Shure: 刚刚不是开过了吗
Shure: Didn't you just turn it on?
Shure: 但是你没有解锁
Shure: But you didn't unlock it.
Lucia: 情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: How come you're so calm?
Shure: 你不是要远程吗
Shure: Aren't you going to remote access?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 我就没没给你关
Shure: I didn't turn it off for you.
Lucia: 卡皮巴拉转世
Lucia: Capybara reincarnation.
Shure: 你得解锁完才能
Shure: You need to unlock it first.
Jake:吐一下怎么了哈哈哈
Jake: So what if I throw up, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈你说到卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Haha, speaking of capybaras,
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia: 我这里有一个特别可爱的表情包
Lucia: I have a really cute sticker pack here.
Shure: 5426883还是87877
Shure: 5426883 or 87877?
Jake:我我要学一下这到底是个什么玩意
Jake: I need to learn, what is this thing?
Lucia: 哦我给你看
Lucia: Oh, let me show you.
Lucia: 我发给你我发给你
Lucia: I'll send it to you, I'll send it to you.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 你在哪呢
Lucia: Where are you?
Jake:我真不知道
Jake: I really don't know.
Shure: 然后帮我把那个向日葵拆开
Shure: And then help me take apart that sunflower.
Jake:在这在这在这在这在这
Jake: Here, here, here, here, here.
Lucia: 找不着你了
Lucia: I can't find you.
Lucia: 不是我给你看那个表情包
Lucia: No, I'll show you that meme.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 在这找到你
Lucia: Found you here.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
其他人：一小时14分钟啊
Others: One hour and 14 minutes.
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Exactly.
其他人：丢了6分钟
Others: Lost 6 minutes.
Lucia: 这个是这是这这个吧
Lucia: This one, this one, this one, right?
其他人 ：对对对对
Others: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 我从我朋友那里捞来的一个表情包
Lucia: I got this meme from my friend.
Lucia: 就特别可爱
Lucia: It's super cute.
Lucia: 下午好有什么倒忙是我能帮的吗哈
Lucia: Good afternoon, is there any trouble I can help with?
Jake:哈哈有什么倒盲是需要我能帮的吗
Jake: Haha, is there any trouble you need my help with?
Shure: 我打打打
Shure: I'll, I'll, I'll...
Shure: 屁游戏我看一眼啊
Shure: Just a game, let me take a look.
Lucia: 哈就这个动物
Lucia: Haha, this animal...
Lucia: 它情绪特别稳定
Lucia: Its mood is super stable.
Jake:这个是他
Jake: This is it.
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Jake:为什么叫
Jake: Why is it called...
Lucia: 它很可爱
Lucia: It's very cute.
Shure: 可以了没问题
Shure: It's fine, no problem.
Jake:他的学名就叫这个名字
Jake: Its scientific name is this.
Lucia: 它的学名就叫这个
Lucia: Its scientific name is this.
Lucia: 它学名就叫卡皮巴拉吧好像
Lucia: I think its scientific name is capybara.
其他人 ：他叫水豚
Others: It's called capybara.
Shure: 阿里嘎斗
Shure: Arigato.
Jake:水豚那为什么叫巴拉
Jake: Capybara, then why is it called 'bara'?
Jake:巴拉是什么
Jake: What is 'bara'?
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 英语翻译过来好像
Lucia: The English translation seems to...
其他人 ：就是有个有个BGM老跟他视频就是谁
Others: There's this BGM that always plays in his videos, who is that?
Shure: 你滚你滚
Shure: Get lost, get lost.
Shure: 你别开别瞎开
Shure: Don't mess around.
Lucia: 哦他
Lucia: Oh, him.
Lucia: 好像他英语就叫卡皮巴拉
Lucia: I think his English name is Capybara.
Shure: 好拜拜
Shure: Okay, bye-bye.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 是吗好像是他
Lucia: Is it? Seems like it's him.
Katrina: 反正有个BGM总
Katrina: Anyway, there's always this BGM.
Lucia: 有个BGM总是这样配的
Lucia: There's always this BGM that matches.
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yeah, it is.
Jake:它为什么是水豚
Jake: Why is it called capybara?
Jake:它是在水里的吗
Jake: Is it because it lives in the water?
Katrina: 是这样会
Katrina: Yeah, kind of.
Lucia: 的是他
Lucia: Yes, it's him.
Jake:怎么可以上圈
Jake: How can it join the circle?
Lucia: 超可爱我觉得好像小马
Lucia: It's super cute, I think it's like a little pony.
Jake:好像小马小驴刚吃过
Jake: Looks like a little pony or a little donkey that just ate.
Lucia: 这个可以吃吗
Lucia: Can you eat this?
Lucia: 应该不可以吃
Lucia: Probably not.
Jake:这个不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Shure: 他好像不是什么保护动物
Shure: It's probably not a protected animal.
Lucia: 这种那个
Lucia: This kind of...
Lucia: 那个字念什么
Lucia: What's that word?
Lucia: 啮齿还是什么类啮
Lucia: Rodent or something like that.
Jake:啮齿嗯
Jake: Rodent, yeah.
Shure: 啮齿类
Shure: Rodents.
Lucia: 对那个动物那那一类的都不可以吃吧
Lucia: Right, animals in that category shouldn't be eaten, right?
其他人：电量特别低的时候是开开不了的吗
Others: When the battery is very low, can't it be turned on?
其他人：但是它在充电
Others: But it's charging.
其他人：是哪个车
Others: Which car is it?
Jake:没有它就是他得一直亮着他才充电
Jake: No, it needs to stay on for it to charge.
Jake:嗯你现在才是100%
Jake: Hmm, now it's 100%.
Lucia: 如果很低的话
Lucia: If it's really low...
Jake:显然是没有充的
Jake: Obviously, it's not charging.
Lucia: 如果很低的话他现在开不了
Lucia: If it's really low, it can't turn on now.
Lucia: 他得充一会才能再
Lucia: It needs to charge a bit first.
Jake:对就是你虽然是插上了但是他没有充
Jake: Yeah, even if it's plugged in, it's not charging.
Jake:他没有开机
Jake: It's not turned on.
Jake:充电宝没有开
Jake: The power bank is not on.
Jake:就他一点电都没有耗嘛
Jake: He didn't use any electricity at all.
Jake:对吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: cup people
Shure: Cup people.
其他人 ：你怎么什么梗都能接住
Others: How can you catch every joke?
Lucia: 10级冲浪大师
Lucia: Level 10 surfing master.
Katrina: 一天24小时28小时上网
Katrina: Online 28 hours a day.
Lucia: 28小时上网
Lucia: 28 hours online.
Lucia: 我们这里的AI好多呀
Lucia: We have so many AIs here.
Lucia: 全天候在线
Lucia: Online around the clock.
Jake:只是插根网线
Jake: Just plug in a network cable.
Jake:就我们插的是电线
Jake: But we plug in a power cord.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:他插的是网线
Jake: He plugs in a network cable.
Shure: 跟我的云服务器已经同步了
Shure: Synced with my cloud server.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不我不是AI
Lucia: No, I'm not an AI.
Lucia: 我只是一直输了
Lucia: I just keep losing.
Jake:你这什么环境
Jake: What kind of environment is this?
Shure: 我是
Shure: I am.
Lucia: 哈哈哈还这个
Lucia: Haha, this too.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么了谢宾主
Shure: What's up, Xie Binzhu?
Shure: 秦明珠刚才叫我
Shure: Qin Mingzhu just called me.
Jake:他他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Katrina: 没叫你啊
Katrina: He didn't call you.
Shure: 他不是肖秀硕吗
Shure: Isn't he Xiao Xiushuo?
Lucia: 他你可你可能收到了他的无限讯号
Lucia: Maybe you received his infinite signal.
其他人：他在下面讲
Others: He's talking downstairs.
其他人 ：他在下面真的讲
Others: He's really talking downstairs.
Katrina: 没听见他喊啊
Katrina: I didn't hear him call.
Jake:我也没听见好强啊
Jake: I didn't hear either, so strong.
Lucia: 我也没听见
Lucia: I didn't hear either.
Katrina: 你俩心灵感应啊
Katrina: You two have telepathy?
Jake:你们是哪个频段
Jake: Which frequency are you on?
Jake:频段的哈哈哈
Jake: Frequency, hahaha.
Jake:是多少赫兹
Jake: How many hertz?
Jake:哈哈哈可以不必谈
Jake: Hahaha, no need to discuss.
Shure: 我要搜啥来着啊腾讯云
Shure: What was I supposed to search for, Tencent Cloud?
Jake:我们还缺什么要买的吗
Jake: Do we need to buy anything else?
Jake:下午采购去
Jake: Let's go shopping in the afternoon.
Jake:有必要吗
Jake: Is it necessary?
Shure: 可以远程盒马的这次
Shure: We can use Hema remotely this time.
Lucia: 盒马送货上门啊
Lucia: Hema delivers to your door.
Jake:咱要不换一家
Jake: How about we switch to another place?
Jake:总盒马的是
Jake: We always use Hema.
Shure: 对主要盒马
Shure: Yes, mainly Hema.
Lucia: 如果是买吃的
Lucia: If it's for buying food.
Shure: 算是国内唯一一个这么好用的商超
Shure: It's the only really good supermarket in the country.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 就是能和也不能说能和山姆
Shure: It can compete with, well, maybe not quite compete with Sam's.
Lucia: 河马不是一直是那个谁
Lucia: Isn't Hema always linked with, you know who.
Lucia: 阿里那边的吗
Lucia: With Alibaba, right?
Jake:日子不好过呀
Jake: Times are tough.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Lucia: 今年淘宝
Lucia: This year Taobao.
Lucia: 今年年初的时候开始
Lucia: Since the beginning of this year.
Lucia: 淘宝也一直在搞新的市场
Lucia: Taobao has been exploring new markets.
Lucia: 市场攻略
Lucia: Market strategies.
Shure: 为什么我这个c键就输不进去呢我操
Shure: Why won't my C key work, damn it.
Lucia: 我们除了奶油还要买什么来着
Lucia: Besides cream, what else do we need to buy?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈显腿细
Shure: Hahaha, makes the legs look slim.
Jake:得问他喽
Jake: We should ask him.
Jake:买啥呀买啥呀
Jake: What do we need to buy?
其他人：买什么买
Others: What to buy, what to buy?
其他人  ：买水果买淡奶油
Others: Buy fruits, buy light cream.
Katrina: 谁会喜欢55岁老头啊
Katrina: Who would like a 55-year-old man?
Lucia: 咱冰箱里还有两块牛排呢
Lucia: We still have two steaks in the fridge.
Katrina: 嘿嘿好帅
Katrina: Haha, so handsome.
Katrina: 套着好帅
Katrina: Looks so handsome in it.
Katrina: 我要练老皮
Katrina: I want to practice old tunes.
Katrina: 你看这这像55岁的吗
Katrina: Look at this, does this look like he's 55?
Jake:谁呀
Jake: Who is it?
Jake:哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's okay.
Shure: 感觉我55岁差不多这个样子
Shure: I feel like I'll look like this at 55.
Shure: 迷倒一片老太太
Shure: Charming all the old ladies.
Katrina: 55岁在抱着那吉他上人民公园
Katrina: At 55, holding that guitar in People's Park.
Katrina: 去唱摇滚去
Katrina: Singing rock and roll.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:靠那5个一个币
Jake: Those five for one coin.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:活下活下半生一个币
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:活下半生
Katrina: 以后相亲
Katrina: Next time on a date
Katrina: 简历上面写本人有5个一狗币
Katrina: I'll write on my resume that I have 5 dogecoin.
Shure: 这边开着两个远程桌面
Shure: Running two remote desktops here.
Jake:BGM吗这是
Jake: Is this the BGM?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Yeah yeah.
Alice:北京野生动物园
Alice: Beijing Wildlife Park.
Alice:不是有那个咖啡吧啦吗
Alice: Isn't there that coffee bar?
Alice:好多人去跟他合影
Alice: Lots of people go take photos with it.
Alice:就拿个水果啊啥顶在他的头上
Alice: They put a fruit or something on its head.
Alice:反而他也不动
Alice: And it doesn't even move.
Alice:就是活也可以不死
Alice: Just living, not dying.
Alice:不活也行
Alice: Or not living, either way.
Alice:哈哈哈活着也行死了也行
Alice: Hahaha, living is fine, dying is fine.
Katrina: 活着也行
Katrina: Living is fine.
Katrina: 死了也行随便你
Katrina: Dying is fine, up to you.
Alice:随便你就你这种精神状态
Alice: Up to you, with your mental state.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 领先人类100年
Lucia: 100 years ahead of humanity.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:放个榴莲在头上
Jake: Put a durian on your head.
Alice:哈哈顶橘子就橘子上面再放橘子
Alice: Haha, just put an orange, then another orange on top.
Shure: 榴莲好像他顶着有点费劲
Shure: A durian might be a bit tricky to balance.
Jake:就像哦
Jake: Just like, oh.
Alice:就像顶杂技一样
Alice: Like a balancing act.
Alice:就不不动不管
Alice: It doesn't move, doesn't care.
Alice:淡淡的死亡感
Alice: A faint sense of death.
Alice:活着也行不活也行随便你
Alice: Living is fine, not living is fine, up to you.
Alice:估计快递也快到
Alice: The delivery should be here soon.
Jake:拆快递你们
Jake: Are you guys opening packages?
Jake:拆快递
Jake: Opening packages.
Lucia: 然后布置
Lucia: And then decorating.
Jake:你们对
Jake: You guys are right.
Lucia: 然后收拾
Lucia: And then clean up.
Alice:该布置了
Alice: It's time to decorate.
Jake:哎布置那个问答
Jake: Yeah, decorate the Q&A area.
Alice:还要收拾
Alice: We still need to tidy up.
Jake:问答的话GPT得干活啊
Jake: For the Q&A, GPT needs to do some work.
Lucia: PPT出完我们来检查一下吧
Lucia: Let's check the PPT after it's done.
Lucia: 要不然他胡说八道
Lucia: Otherwise, it might talk nonsense.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:每天都让他有一个胡说八道的机会
Jake: Every day, we let it have a chance to talk nonsense.
Lucia: 每天都
Lucia: Every day?
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Alice:还是不知道为什么
Alice: I still don't get why.
Alice:那个什么一多少来着
Alice: That thing, how much was it?
Jake:那个什么 1132132是回文数
Jake: That thing, 1132132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 要
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:还有那个为什么代表3月21
Alice: And why does it represent March 21?
Jake:也没整明白
Jake: I didn't get it either.
Lucia: 带
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:为什么能用16多少来着代表
Alice: Why can it be used to represent 16 something?
Jake:对这这这
Jake: Yeah, this, this, this.
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: One...
Jake:太离谱了这个
Jake: This is too ridiculous.
Alice:161 还是161吧
Alice: 161 or 161, right?
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, seems like it.
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why though?
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:他是说
Jake: He said...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:161这个数字代表国际植树节3月21号
Jake: 161 stands for International Arbor Day on March 21.
Jake:尽管他与世世界地球日不是同一天
Jake: Even though it's not the same day as Earth Day.
Alice:哈哈哈那我是不是还能代表328
Alice: Haha, then I can also represent 328.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:尽管他们不是同一个数字哈哈哈
Alice: Even though they are not the same number, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:是这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他哪怕把那个3月21除以2我都能接受
Lucia: Even if he divided March 21 by 2, I could accept that.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 他给了一个什么奇怪的东西
Lucia: What strange thing did he give?
Jake:139 这个数字
Jake: The number 139
Jake:象征着地球大气中主要气体的数量
Jake: It symbolizes the number of major gases in the Earth's atmosphere.
Lucia: 是139种吗
Lucia: Are there 139 kinds?
Jake:我觉得不是
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Lucia: 不是一共就那么几种吗
Lucia: Aren't there only a few kinds in total?
Jake:他应该是组组了一个什么
Jake: He probably put together something.
Alice:他说气体数量
Alice: He said the number of gases.
Jake:CO2 是吗
Jake: CO2, right?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What thing?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:192
Jake: 192
Jake:这个数字可以象征全世界
Jake: This number can symbolize the whole world.
Jake:大概有192个国家
Jake: There are about 192 countries.
Alice:元素
Alice: Elements.
Jake:需要参加世界地球日的活动
Jake: That need to participate in World Earth Day activities.
Jake:这是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 只有192个国家
Lucia: Only 192 countries?
Alice:一共
Alice: In total.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:一百得二百多吧
Jake: More than 200, I think.
Jake:我感觉
Jake: I feel like.
Lucia: 好像吧
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice:有的没资格参加吗
Alice: Some can't participate?
Alice:这意思吗
Alice: Is that what it means?
Lucia: 没加入联合国吗
Lucia: Not in the UN?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, no idea.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈咱也不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, we don't know either.
Jake:108 在许多文化中
Jake: 108, in many cultures.
Jake:108是个神圣的数字
Jake: 108 is a sacred number.
Jake:象征着宇宙的和谐和完整
Jake: It symbolizes harmony and completeness of the universe.
Alice:啊是
Alice: Oh, really?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 啊真的吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Jake:也代也代表着
Jake: It also represents
Lucia: 我刚想到的是水浒里面的好汉
Lucia: What I just thought of was the heroes from Water Margin
Jake:对就这个水浒宇宙的完整
Jake: Yeah, the complete Water Margin universe
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great
Shure: 水浒宇宙可还行
Shure: Water Margin universe, really?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:水浒宇宙
Alice: Water Margin universe
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:没问题吧
Jake: No problem, right?
Alice:没问题
Alice: No problem
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem
Lucia: 没问题写万事皆可宇宙
Lucia: No problem, just write "Everything Universe"
Jake:水护宇宙
Jake: Water Margin universe
Jake:水浒宇宙
Lucia: 都是那两个漫画公司折腾出来的破事
Lucia: It's all the mess created by those two comic companies
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes
Lucia: 不过我从我从高中开始看DC和漫威
Lucia: But I've been reading DC and Marvel since high school
Lucia: 然后一直看到现在
Lucia: And have been reading until now
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm
Lucia: 然后每天都每天都在
Lucia: And every day, every day
Shure: OK牛逼了家人们
Shure: Okay, impressive, guys
Lucia: 就是精神股东
Lucia: I'm like a spiritual shareholder
Lucia: 和期待这两个公司破产的边缘摇摆
Lucia: Swinging between hoping these two companies go bankrupt
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Lucia: 因为我觉得你们写出来那种狗屎故事
Lucia: Because I think the stories they write are crap
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 要不然还是别编了哈哈哈
Lucia: Maybe they should just stop writing, haha
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's one more
Jake:这个 197这个数字代表1970年
Jake: This number 197 represents the year 1970
Jake:那一年首次庆祝了地球日这个数
Jake: That year was the first time Earth Day was celebrated
Jake:字具有重要的历史和纪念意义
Jake: This number has important historical significance
Jake:看对不对
Jake: See if I'm right
Lucia: 我估计他就是算准了
Lucia: I guess he just assumed
Lucia: 有些东西你也不能确定
Lucia: There are some things you can't be sure of
Lucia: 所以他就在这乱说
Lucia: So he just made things up
Jake:对他就是乱说
Jake: Yeah, he's just making things up
Jake:这个确实是真的 1970年
Jake: But this is true, 1970
Shure: 怎么跟大张伟那死动静似的
Shure: Why does it sound like Da Zhang Wei's dead sound
Shure: 把这个大屏幕打开然后
Shure: Turn on this big screen then
Jake:然后
Jake: And then
Shure: 想想地球日的题目
Shure: Think about the theme for Earth Day.
Jake:行啊来吧
Jake: Sure, let's do it.
Jake:谁有那什么账号
Jake: Who has that account?
Shure: 哎把那俩遥控器给我去
Shure: Hey, pass me those two remotes.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Jake:遥控器是在这
Jake: The remote is here.
Jake:所以他开了是吧
Jake: So it's turned on, right?
Lucia: 问大家132为什么是回文书
Lucia: Ask everyone why 132 is a palindrome.
Jake:嗯哦问问他是吧
Jake: Hmm, oh, ask him, right?
Lucia: 对就把这个做
Lucia: Yes, make that the topic.
Lucia: 不是把这个作为一个题目
Lucia: No, make this a topic.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:让大家乱编
Jake: Let everyone make up stuff.
Lucia: 对对对我可能会被全场人打神经病
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes, I might get called crazy by everyone.
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Everyone is GBT.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Huh?
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Everyone is GBT.
Jake:弱智吧哈哈哈
Jake: They are dumb, hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:我们要不就弱智吧题目里面抽几个
Jake: How about we draw a few from the dumb topics?
Jake:得了吧哈哈哈
Jake: Never mind, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我又想起来昨天那个北京是什么
Lucia: I just remembered, what was that about Beijing yesterday?
Lucia: 我说直辖市
Lucia: I said it's a municipality.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 我没看到他指的那辆车
Lucia: I didn't see the car he was pointing at.
Lucia: 我以为你
Lucia: I thought you
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:这太典型了这个
Jake: That's so typical.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 我以为你真的在正儿八经的问
Lucia: I thought you were seriously asking.
Jake:哈哈哈正儿八经的问北京市
Jake: Hahaha, seriously asking about Beijing.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 所以对
Lucia: So, yeah
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Lucia: 然后我就没有感觉到这个问题的意义
Lucia: And then I just didn't feel the significance of this question
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈哈就送来一个正确的回答
Jake: Hahaha, just send the correct answer
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 对啊这个肯定不会出错吧
Lucia: Yeah, this definitely won't go wrong, right?
Lucia: 谁知道你问的是车呢
Lucia: Who knew you were talking about a car?
Jake:所以试试吧那个车
Jake: So, give it a try, that car
Lucia: 不知道不了解
Lucia: I don't know, no idea
Lucia: 就是有一个车牌子叫北京
Lucia: There's a car brand called Beijing
Lucia: 汽车厂牌
Lucia: Automaker brand
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:弱智吗那个什么陨石
Jake: Is it dumb, that meteor thing?
Jake:为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑呢
Jake: Why does it always hit the crater accurately?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 现在是冷笑话时间了是
Lucia: So it's time for cold jokes now?
Alice:hahahaha
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈太蠢了
Shure: Haha, so dumb
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is it?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
其他人 ：哎呦我受不了了
Others: Oh, I can't take it anymore
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
其他人 ：卧槽太傻逼了
Others: Damn, that's so stupid
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:就是弱智吧
Jake: It's just dumb, right?
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Jake:这被门夹过的核桃还能还能补
Jake: These walnuts crushed by the door can still be fixed?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:还能补脑
Jake: It can also boost your brainpower.
Jake:多少被门夹过
Jake: How many times have you been pinched by a door?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:喝杯豆汁压压惊吧哈哈哈
Jake: Have a cup of soybean milk to calm your nerves, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 我们是要给恋爱吃什么
Katrina: What should we feed the love?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:这个已经用起来了
Jake: This one is already in use.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:就是AI里边就是有一个研究
Jake: There's a study in AI...
Jake:就是说用弱智巴的这个数据做训练
Jake: That uses data from the intellectually disabled for training.
Jake:然后效果比别人
Jake: And the results are better than others.
Jake:哈哈哈哎
Jake: Hahaha, hey.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:你这个灯是没有了啊
Jake: Your light is gone now.
Katrina: 灯没有了吗
Katrina: The light is gone?
Shure: 灯怎么变红了
Shure: Why did the light turn red?
Jake:啊红的
Jake: Ah, it's red.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:要不你看一下手机对
Jake: Why don't you check your phone?
Jake:对你看一下啊这个
Jake: Yes, check this on your phone.
Jake:手机软件
Jake: The phone app.
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴吗
Alice: If a pregnant woman hits someone, is it considered a group fight?
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴
Alice: A pregnant woman hitting someone is considered a group fight.
Jake:哈哈哈哈对这个点
Jake: Hahaha, yes, that's the point.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:这个很点
Jake: That's very relevant.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Jake:看看看看你的这个状态
Jake: Check your status.
Jake:他应该就是过热呀之类的
Jake: It should be overheating or something like that.
Alice:他肚子里有一个哈哈
Alice: There's one inside his belly, haha.
Shure: 啊过热
Shure: Ah, overheating.
Jake:火热火热
Jake: Very hot, very hot.
Shure: 过热
Shure: Overheating.
Jake:那你就come down
Jake: Then you should just calm down.
Jake:come down哈哈哈
Jake: Calm down, hahaha.
Shure: 我我come on好像呵呵
Shure: I... I... come on, seems like... haha
Katrina: 我看不到
Katrina: I can't see
Alice:笑死
Alice: Hilarious
Jake:你come down
Jake: You come down
Alice:然后就提示说就是recording停止
Alice: Then it just said that the recording stopped
Alice:但是之前的这个
Alice: But before that...
Jake:哦没关系再开一个吧
Jake: Oh, it's fine, just start another one
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's fine, it's fine
Jake:没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
Jake:早上好啊
Jake: Good morning
Jake:你这还亮着吗
Jake: Is this still on?
Jake:你这一直不插电亮着吗
Jake: Is this still on without being plugged in?
Jake:那当然不亮了
Jake: Of course it’s not on
Jake:你不插电呀
Jake: You didn't plug it in
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:可多了还有吃健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jake: There's so much, can you get full just eating digestive tablets?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 受不了了
Shure: I can't take it anymore
Shure: 他怎么卡死了卧槽
Shure: Why is it frozen, damn
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly
Jake:用这东西来训练AI的话
Jake: Using this to train AI
Jake:因为他要回答他就需要很多逻辑
Jake: Because for it to respond, it needs a lot of logic
Alice:真的需要很多逻辑
Alice: It really needs a lot of logic
Alice:你确定吗哈哈
Alice: Are you sure? Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:就是因为训练的时候
Jake: Because during training
Jake:会给他一个人写的答案
Jake: It will give a human-written answer
Jake:对然后人写答案
Jake: Right, then the human-written answer
Jake:就是他会一本正经的去回答这个问题
Jake: It will answer the question seriously
Jake:就是吃健胃消食片什么什么功效
Jake: Like what are the effects of digestive tablets
Jake:什么什么对
Jake: Stuff like that, yeah
音乐声：my only intentions baby
Music: my only intentions baby
Alice:笑死了
Alice: Dying of laughter
音乐声：keep looking up at your own breath
Music: keep looking up at your own breath
音乐声：heart full of radio games
Music: heart full of radio games
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吗哈哈哈
Jake: Will infertility be inherited? Hahaha 社会问题
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 我受不了
Katrina: I can't take it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哈哈牛
Jake: Haha, awesome.
Jake:充电宝不剁了
Jake: No more chopping up the power bank.
Katrina: 地球上有30%的海洋
Katrina: Earth has 30% ocean.
Katrina: 和百分之70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Katrina: And 70% ocean and 30% land.
Katrina: 那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地去哪了
Katrina: So where did the remaining 30% ocean and 70% land go?
Jake:啥 70%
Jake: What? 70%?
Katrina: 地球上有70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Katrina: The Earth has 70% ocean and 30% land.
Katrina: 那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地是吗
Katrina: So where did the remaining 30% ocean and 70% land go?
Jake:哈哈哈哈好吧哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, alright, hahaha.
Jake:插电了吗
Jake: Did you plug it in?
其他人：卡个东西好插个电哈
Others: Just stick something in and plug it in, haha.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈滚哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, get out, hahaha.
Katrina: 关羽不斩老六
Katrina: Guan Yu didn't kill the old six.
Katrina: 为什么不派十万老六去斩杀关羽
Katrina: Why didn't they send 100,000 old sixes to kill Guan Yu?
Shure: 太傻逼了
Shure: So stupid.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't take it.
Jake:哈哈这好好有
Jake: Haha, this is so good.
Jake:哈哈哈好有道理我靠
Jake: Hahaha, it makes so much sense, damn.
Jake:这出题吧
Jake: Let's come up with a question.
Jake:咱也别世界地球人
Jake: Let's not be Earthlings.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我明天表演的那个
Others: The one I'm performing tomorrow.
其他人：我明天表演的节目就是给大家讲笑话
Others: The show I'm doing tomorrow is telling jokes to everyone.
Jake:可以
Jake: Cool.
Jake:咱充上了吗
Jake: Did we charge it?
Jake:咱要不开机
Jake: Should we turn it on?
Jake:又挂了是吧又挂了
Jake: It crashed again, right? Crashed again.
其他人：写遗嘱的时候因为拖延症错
Others: While writing a will, they made a mistake because of procrastination.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 那真的是呆懒
Katrina: That's really lazy.
Jake:哈哈然后然后出来问问题
Jake: Haha, then came out to ask questions.
Katrina: 心语听力考试
Katrina: Heart language listening test.
Katrina: 总是听到两个人在广播里唠嗑
Katrina: Always hearing two people chatting on the broadcast.
Katrina: 干扰我做题
Katrina: Distracting me from doing the questions.
Katrina: 怎么能把那两个人撵走
Katrina: How can I drive those two away?
Jake: ：哈哈
Jake: Haha.
音乐声：i wanna see you everywhere with me
Music: I wanna see you everywhere with me
Shure: 找不到这个
Shure: Can't find this
音乐声：and i will wake up with no one next to me
Music: And I will wake up with no one next to me
音乐声：so won't you come back to me
Music: So won't you come back to me
其他人 ：充的没有用的快
Others: The charge doesn't last long
Jake:正正月剪头被舅舅制止并暴打一顿
Jake: Cutting hair during the first month of the lunar year was stopped by my uncle and I got beaten up.
Jake:舅舅舅是否得逞后正当防卫
Jake: Did my uncle defend himself after achieving his goal?
Shure: 啊还有那个
Shure: Ah, there's also that
Jake:哈哈哈哈傻傻傻
Jake: Hahahaha, silly silly silly
Shure: 那个
Shure: That
其他人：这要问罗强奥
Others: You should ask Luo Qiang
Jake:是哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, hahaha
Shure: 舅舅那个正月剪头不是死舅舅吗
Shure: Isn't cutting hair during the first month of the lunar year supposed to kill the uncle?
Shure: 然后如果呢
Shure: And if
Shure: 我正月烫头的话
Shure: I perm my hair during the first month
Shure: 那舅舅会变弯吗哈哈哈
Shure: Will my uncle become bent? Hahaha 性别问题
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
其他人：今年过年的时候
Others: During this New Year
其他人：真的就有这个正月剪头的
Others: Someone really did cut their hair in the first month
其他人：然后他舅他舅妈把他侄子给起诉了
Others: And his uncle and aunt sued his nephew
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
其他人：啊？起诉了
Others: Huh? Sued him?
Jake: OK
其他人：就觉得就是他剪头让他老公死了吗
Others: They thought cutting his hair caused her husband to die
其他人：他老公真的死了
Others: Her husband really died
其他人：真的死了
Others: Really died
Katrina: 这么容易死啊
Katrina: Died that easily?
其他人：真容易死就抢回了
Others: Died so easily and got him back
Katrina: 这么容易死药也没用
Katrina: Died so easily, even medicine is useless
Jake:其他人
Jake and others
其他人：然后他舅妈真的把他给起诉了
Others: And then his aunt really sued him
Katrina: 之前你看过那个台湾的那个综艺没有
Katrina: Did you see that Taiwanese show before?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 说有一个女生说什么什么打耳洞那边
Katrina: A girl said something about piercing ears causing misfortune to the husband
其他人 ：住下水道
Others: Living in the sewer
Katrina: 打耳洞什么克老公
Katrina: Piercing ears causing husband's death
Jake:哈哈住下水道靠
Jake: Hahaha, living in the sewer, damn
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe
Katrina: 那人说老公这么容易死要老公干什么
Katrina: If husbands die that easily, what's the point of having one?
Katrina: 没看过那个搞笑的超搞笑
Katrina: Haven't seen that super funny one.
其他人：什么时候去超市
Others: When are we going to the supermarket?
Jake:好呀
Jake: Sure.
其他人：我问什么时候
Others: I asked when.
其他人：你说好呀
Others: And you just said sure.
Jake:我看一看
Jake: Let me check.
其他人 ：哦你不饿
Others: Oh, you're not hungry.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：就是好呀
Others: Just sure.
其他人：不道呀哈哈
Others: No idea, haha.
其他人：我有罪对不起哈哈哈
Others: I'm guilty, sorry, haha.
音乐声：you see i can be
Music: you see i can be
音乐声：sleep
Music: sleep
音乐声：i can't breathe
Music: i can't breathe
Katrina: 早知道最后被第三志愿录取
Katrina: If I had known, I would have been accepted by my third choice.
Katrina: 第三志愿应该舔清华了
Katrina: My third choice should have been Tsinghua.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈说不出话来
Jake: Hahahahaha, I can't even speak.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
音乐声 ：太傻逼了
Music: So stupid.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 说不出话来
Shure: I can't even speak.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 那你就可能被第40人录取了
Shure: Then you might get accepted by the 40th choice.
Jake:那你就可能被第四志愿录取了
Jake: Then you might get accepted by your fourth choice.
Jake:走收波眼镜
Jake: Let's go collect the glasses.
Jake:然后打完咱就走
Jake: And then we'll leave after that.
Shure: 抖
Shure: Shake.
其他人：哦那我不连了啊
Others: Oh, then I won't connect.
其他人：刚准备连
Others: I was just about to connect.
Jake:哦你不连了故意的
Jake: Oh, you won't connect, on purpose.
其他人：（歌声）一定是上天的安排
Others: (Singing) It must be fate's arrangement.
Jake:哈哈关关关
Jake: Haha, turn it off.
Jake:关掉关掉
Jake: Turn it off, turn it off.
Katrina: and we
Jake:昨天晚上微微让我破防了
Jake: Last night, Weiwei really broke me down.
Jake:大大的破防
Jake: Completely broke me.
Jake:他昨天告诉我说三亚的酒店
Jake: He told me yesterday that the hotel in Sanya...
Jake:三亚的别墅是
Jake: The villa in Sanya is...
Jake:吧三层游泳池
Jake: ...three stories with a swimming pool.
Jake:大别墅
Jake: A big villa.
Jake:一天100多
Jake: Costs over 100 a day.
其他人：还有游泳池啊
Others: It has a swimming pool too?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:咳咳
Jake: *cough cough*
其他人：他又不是胃口
Others: It's not an appetite thing.
Jake:就是最近
Jake: It's just recently...
其他人 ：自己停止然后那个啥了
Others: It stops by itself and then...
Jake:哦好奇怪
Jake: Oh, that's so strange.
其他人：你要不要检修一下
Others: Do you need to get it checked?
Jake:好吧我我也不知道该怎么办
Jake: Alright, I don't know what to do.
其他人：那要不要告诉他大理的事情
Others: Should we tell him about Dali?
Jake:大理也是
Jake: Dali is also...
Jake:多少钱
Jake: ...how much?
其他人：可是那种应该只是那种别墅吧
Others: But it should be just a villa, right?
其他人   ：呃有那种整租的
Others: Uh, there's the whole rental type.
其他人：不会很贵
Others: It's not very expensive.
其他人：就可能就是最多乘2吧
Others: At most, it would be double.
其他人：整租的民宿
Others: Entire rental BnB.
其他人：整要说吗
Others: Should we say the whole thing?
其他人：差不多一个月2,0002,000
Others: About 2,000 a month.
其他人：一个月2,000
Others: 2,000 a month.
Jake:咱这一天
Jake: For us, a day...